hey guys do you know your own face shape
the reason i'm asking this is because
there's a lot of guys out there who
reach out to me asking me daniel
what kind of hairstyle will fit in with
me what kind of
beard should i try well when i start to
speak to them i realize
they don't really know their face shape
so
let's start at the beginning let's start
at the basics because you need to know
your
face shape before you will know what
kind of hairstyles and beard styles will
fit in
with you specifically so in this video
i'm going to quickly explain to you
exactly how you can determine
your face shape let's get to it
i have a dream that's all i need
i'll make it happen
now just very quick if it's your first
time here on my channel i'm daniel
moritz and welcome to dlm moral
lifestyle if you haven't subscribed yet
then please consider it so you won't
miss any of the next videos
now let's start to determine your face
shape let's do it together
there are seven basic face shapes you
got oval
square rectangle round diamond
heart and triangular now let's find out
what face shape you got
first get a flexible tape measure and
get a notebook
now the first step is to measure your
forehead measure the widest part of your
forehead across your face
from the peak of one eyebrow arch to the
opposite side
write it down step two we're going to
measure our cheekbones
place the tape across the pointiest
parts just below the outer corner of
each
eye step three the jawline
start below your ear and then measure it
to the tip of your chin
okay now just double it for the other
side
and write it down step four which is the
last one we're going to measure the
length
of your face start at the center of your
hairline to the tip
of your chin it's important to do this
accurately because the difference
between a square face and a rectangular
face is only around
2 inches so you got to do it accurately
all right so the last thing we got to do
is to compare
your measurements with all the different
face shapes and see
which one is yours now the key here is
to look
at the measurement that is the biggest
the largest
let's start with the diamond shape if
you have a diamond shape your face
length is
the largest your cheekbone is the second
biggest and then your forehead
and lastly the jawline which is the
smallest
next triangular if you have a triangular
face shape
your jawline is the biggest the jawline
is bigger than the cheekbones and the
cheekbones
larger than the forehead now if you have
a hard face shape your forehead is
bigger than your cheekbones and your
jawline
the chin is also usually pointed out a
bit more
now if you have a round face your face
length and cheekbones are
roughly the same size and it is bigger
than your jawline
and forehead now just one thing you
gotta remember here
if you are a little bit overweight you
might think that you are born with a
round face
but it might not be true because if you
are overweight
your face will look rounder
so if you want to know your true face
shape you got to lose the weight if you
lose the weight
then you'll see your true face shape now
let's go to the next one the oval
face shape the face length is greater
than the cheekbones and the forehead is
bigger than the jawline
and the jawline is more rounded now if
we go to the square face shape the
square face shape
is easy because all four of the lengths
are usually
similar right only difference in most
cases
is that the jawline is more sharper
now if you have a rectangle or oblong
face shape
your jawline cheekbones and forehead is
roughly the same size
but your face length is the biggest all
right guys now whenever i talk about
different styles and hairstyles and
beard styles and
different face shapes that will look
good with it you'll know
exactly what will look good with you
because now you know your face shape
now stick around watch some of my other
videos here that you haven't seen yet
and i'll see you there cheers guys